have we built in our society a wall of
rationality that his arrows can't
penetrate
are we in danger of losing our capacity
to love and be loved
i think that is the great problem number
ones of
of the aquarian age that we the only
thing which might
save us from falling in the east and the
west
into uh over rationally over
organized mass society in which the
individual is suffocated
and and we have those slogans now in
politics
too much state too much organization and
so on so
people are waking up to the fact of what
is negative
that the computerizing of humanity that
the in having too many rules which are
rules are always impersonal now they are
for everybody
everybody has to keep the rules and so
on all that massification which
comes from the fact of overpopulation
it's not our fault the overpopulation
demands
this organization but that suffocates
the individual
while in if you study primitive
communities or
older agricultural communities everybody
knew
everybody and you everybody personally
and related to each other personally
for instance a lot of idiots
and mentally sick people didn't need to
be internalized because the
community just suffered them they
laughed and they said oh well you know
so and so
i even remember in a village i grew up
the the first day we moved in a man came
and said
my father is a kleptoman and he steals
everything
so if things are stolen from you please
don't go to the police just come to me
and i'll hand them back to you
so you see the poor old man captain man
didn't need to go to an asylum
everybody knew his little fault and
corrected it
that is personal relationship he
he belonged personally to the community
including his
faults and and such a society
can there are less criminals and there
are less people ready for the lunatic
asylums there are
such a community can carry the
individual
or stand the individual and leave it a
certain leeway of freedom
with a kind of shrug of shoulder well he
is like that or she
is like that in a partnering shrug of
the shoulders
people are taking for taken for what
they are
and that's what we have lost and that's
what we have to
restore again in some new form